HOW YOU DOING?
I'M DOING OKAY.
HOW ARE YOU?
I'M NOT SO GOOD,
'CAUSE YOU WERE WEAVING
ALL OVER THE ROAD THERE.
CAN WE GET ONE THING STRAIGHT?
I HAVE NOT BEEN DRINKING.
RIGHT HAND TO THE NOSE...
YEAH.
...WITH THE LEFT HAND
AND BACK OUT.
I NEED YOU TO RECITE
THE ALPHABET
FROM "Z" TO "A" BACKWARDS
AS FAST AS YOU CAN.
FROM "Z" TO "A"? SURE.
UH...
Z...
Y...
X, W, V, U, T, S, R, Q,
P, O, N, M, L, K, J,
I, H, G, F, E, D, C, B, A.
ALL RIGHT.
REMARKABLE.
I'VE ACTUALLY NEVER SEEN
ANYBODY DO THAT.
OH, MY BLADDER IS FULL.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT YOUR
BLADDER RIGHT NOW, OKAY?
ALL RIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT
PRETTY GOOD BALANCE THERE.
I WANT YOU TO STEP, BUMP,
STEP, BUMP-BUMP,
STEP, BUMP,
STEP, BUMP-BUMP.
5, 6, 7, 8.
STEP, BUMP,
STEP, BUMP-BUMP,
STEP, BUMP-BUMP.
PAS DE BARRé, KICK-BALL-CHANGE,
STEP, CLAP.
5, 6, 7, 8.
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD BE GOOD
IS IF YOU KICKED AND THEN
YOU KIND OF...DID THAT
AND THEN A BARREL TURN
AND THEN -- HA!
YOU KNOW?
THAT WAS GOOD.
THAT WAS REALLY GOOD.
YOU A DANCER?
NO. NO, NO, NO.
I'M JUST DRUNK.
AHHHHH!
UP AGAINST THE VEHICLE
RIGHT NOW, SIR.
YOU ARE GOING TO JAIL.